welcome to CBS this morning and we're
starting with the big oil pressure is
growing on president Trump's Labor
Secretary to step down over the Jeffrey
Epstein scandal Democrats are blasting
Alex Acosta for a secret and generous
plea deal he approved for the financier
more than a decade ago when Acosta was
US Attorney in Florida
Epstein served 13 months in jail and was
often released during the day after
being accused of sexually abusing dozens
of underage girls he had to register as
a sex offender
Epstein now faces federal child sex
trafficking charges in New York City
where prosecutors say a rate of his home
turned up hundreds of lewd photos Ben
Tracy is at the White House Ben is
Secretary Acosta's job on the line
well Acosta serves at the pleasure of
the President and so far the president
is standing by him but mr. Trump who has
his own history with Jeffrey Epstein is
giving himself plenty of room to
maneuver if he decides secretary Acosta
has to go I feel very badly actually for
secretary Acosta because I've known him
as being somebody that works so hard and
has done such a good job on Tuesday
president Trump defended his cabinet
secretary while also saying he believes
many judges and attorneys wish they
could have handled things differently
years after the fact I would think you'd
probably find that they would wish they
maybe did it a different way
that's because of a 2008 plea deal
Acosta signed off on when he was a US
Attorney in Miami
Epstein was tried in state court where
he was given a 13-month sentence that
even allowed him to leave jail and go to
work six days a week Acosta made an
agreement with Epstein's attorneys to
keep the plea deal secret from Epstein's
victims Epstein was also granted
immunity from federal charges a Florida
judge ruled Tuesday that prosecutors
violated the law by not consulting
Epstein's victims about the plea deal
Acosta perverted justice to give a very
sweet deal to a to an accused multiple
child molester and is no business in
government many Democrats including
those running for president are now
calling for Acosta's resignation he
defended himself on Twitter Tuesday
saying
with the evidence available more than a
decade ago federal prosecutors insisted
that Epstein go to jail register as a
sex offender and put the world on notice
that he was a sexual predator Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell says
Acosta's fate is up to the president and
the focus should be on Epstein's crimes
there's no question that the accusations
against Epstein or horrendous the
billionaire financier was once friendly
with mr. Trump who sometimes socialized
with Epstein at his mar-a-lago club in
Florida I knew him like everybody in
Palm Beach knew him in a 2002 article
mr. Trump said I've known Jeff for 15
years
terrific guy he's a lot of fun to be
with it is even said that he likes
beautiful women as much as I do and many
of them are on the younger side on
Tuesday the president said something
different I was not a fan of his that I
can tell you I was not a fan of his the
president now says that he had a
falling-out with Jeffrey Epstein about
15 years ago but he won't say why
meanwhile the author James Patterson who
has written about Epstein says that mr.
Trump kicked Epstein out of mar-a-lago
after there were some complaints about
his behavior with young women but the
White House will not confirm that Tony
all right Ben thank you very much